please welcome oh my god i can't believe
i'm saying this norah o'donnell
[Applause]
okay i'm fangirling you right back my
friend oh my gosh
i i can't i i watch you every night this
is so surreal
and so crazy and you came on a very
important day the start of cake week and
all
week long we're shining a light on
special cake
in the news actually cake of the day
let's try this animation
here we go
yeah she's cute um and today it's the
smith island cake
from smith island maryland and
like you made the cake last night
well look i i knew that this was going
to be the cake of the day and i thought
really the only cake that people in
maryland cared about were crab cakes
but it turns out the official dessert of
maryland is the smith island cake
and so i was like all right i gotta know
what this is so
last night what did i do i got grace we
got the pans we went to the grocery
store
and here it is and so i can report to
you
it's a lot of work making i we supposed
to be eight layers only seven turned out
well
but um we made it and i had cake for
breakfast
so thank you i love that and it's a cake
that launched a thousand ships because
for 200 years fishermen took
this cake by their made by their wives
usually
on their annual oyster harvest and the
fudge like
kept it together and congealed without
going bad when they were out on the boat
for a long time so that's the
interesting fun fact about that now
speaking of food you're married to jeff
tracy and he is an amazing restaurateur
he owns six restaurants in washington
d.c
um you guys got married in 2004
is that correct 2001 we were actually
and we've been together
since we were in college so that's right
you met at georgetown
yes so it's going to be 20 20 years
married i guess in 2021
and um we got together when i was 17
and i'm going to turn 47 this year i
mean it's it's
we're we're at this point we're in it
for the long haul
i mean what what is your advice for
people i always ask on this show i'm
sorry this wasn't part of the
pre-interview but i'm always so curious
what is
good advice for the long haul you know
because we live in the society where
swipe left swipe left everybody's a
little add and not investing as much
um or knowing that they have the option
to be free and so
you know they they sometimes get out
what do you think is the recipe for
knowing you can make it through the long
haul it's a good question i mean the
advice my mom had always given me
was um try and marry your best friend
marry someone who respects his own
mother you know and loves his mother and
treats her well
and then i think what's kind of kept us
together is just um
you know we try and do things together
like um you know we
in high in college we used to say a
couple of studies together stays
together
now now we kind of try and take a walk
every morning if we can just you know
non-pressured time together you know
play golf together something like that
so you can just catch up and then
there's a lot of forgiveness involved in
any relationship
i love that i just heard this like it
was a friday night lights quote
like there's no sinning and forgiving
and i was like yes i so
agree now we're going to go to a
commercial break and come back
and do some feel-good stories and
something i just want to say
is that i know that you are the managing
editor
of the cbs evening news so you
are really the grand conductor of the
content and i know that it was a mission
of yours to make sure that you balance
the stuff we all must know
to do our civic duties and be informed
citizens of the world
but you also felt that it was important
to give stories of hope
and functionality i always say that word
just because you know
why was that so important to you yeah
and i think you you said that well it's
like being a conductor and you have to
have a great orchestra on team which we
really do have at cbs news and the
evening news and
you know part of what i said is we cover
a lot of the hard news every day
um but we have to do hard news and then
do heart and so we really try and cover
stories that capture
our common humanity we did a story um
earlier this year about the suit man
his name is peter kelleher i'm up in new
hampshire in new england he's all over
he lost his son to opioid addiction who
then became homeless you know what he
did he got a school bus
and now he goes around and feeds soup
out of homeless people and give them
socks and toiletries and so we went one
day and helped him
you know deliver soup um we did a story
on bitty and bows coffee
a lot of people may know them they now
they now employ hundreds of people with
special needs and the woman who started
amy wright she has two kids bitty and bo
who have down syndrome
and she was like where are they going to
work you know what what's their future
why don't we create a coffee shop
that where special needs people can work
and it's the best coffee and the most
amazing and beautiful people you've ever
met in your life
and so those are kind of the stories
we're trying to highlight
every night on the evening news my
because my mom always said to me
if you capture someone's heart you
capture their mind and so
that's that's one thing i say every
story we do even the hard news stories
make sure we tell people's humanity
and you use the word tone repeatedly in
some of the things you've said in public
about how you conduct your symphony of
the news and i so agree
as like a filmmaker i always thought
tone was
my parameters if i cared about the tone
and the heart everything else the comedy
the action like whatever it would all
work out around it
you